what about the relationships between
science fiction and fantasy and their
changing appeal let us say the mass
audiences you have started out writing
science fiction stories now you're known
as a fantasy writer I wonder if you
could talk a little bit about you know
the choices you make when you choose to
write a story and one genre or the other
and what relationships you think there
are between them and Stan I'd like to
hear a little bit about what you think
those relationships are - well that's an
interesting subject yes when I started
out writing in the early 70s I I did a
few fantasies early on I've been
published in fantastic magazines one of
the digest magazines of the day but
predominantly I published an analogue
and amazing and the magazines were
identified in science fiction magazines
and I wrote a lot of stuff that were set
up other planets with aliens and
starships and all of that stuff I think
a lot of that was not because I didn't I
prefered science fiction to fantasy I
love them both I mean I grew up reading
Robert a Heinlein and Andre Norton were
two writers that I devoured in in my
childhood and really early teenage years
but I also read Robert E Howard and
tokey in for the fantasy HP Lovecraft
and horror
we didn't call it horror then we call it
monster stories I love my monster
stories and having read all this I also
wrote all this when I come of age but in
the sixties and seventies well as in the
70s there were far more markets for
science fiction particularly in the
short story length so that's
predominantly what I write and I love
the world's I created and some of the
stories I told I'm still very proud of
but I you know I look back on it now and
saying you know I was writing fantasy
all along I mean I'm I'm not a hard
science guy like Stan everything that I
know about science I learned from
science fiction stories so
by my science fiction stories if you you
know look at them quick idli here or
really space fantasy I'm using aliens a
sort of elves or whatever it's a it's a
furniture difference rather than I
quantitative difference and I actually
believe that a science fiction and
fantasy are just two flavors are the
same thing I mean one of them is
chocolate ice cream and one of them is
strawberry ice cream but they're both
ice cream and they taste really good now
there are some people who don't believe
that who feel that they're completely
opposites and indeed may even and be in
opposition to each other because science
fiction is real and realistic and you
know could possibly happen and fantasy
is not which is a dubious proposition we
should think about because it doesn't
hold up actually there's far more
evidence for the existence of ghosts
than for hyperspace so what do you think
oh man the border between science
fiction and fantasy is so permeable and
interpenetrated that it can never be
teased out and none of the ways that
people try to do it actually work very
well so it's a game that we play in our
field and some people will argue over it
and other people who realize that it can
never be accomplished because time
travel is usually called science fiction
and yet it's a fantasy and every night
we are always having about three or four
fantasy novels run through our heads
which are our dreams and those dreams
are real and so you could say that it's
a kind of science fiction where where
you drop into your dreams every night
and there are other ways in which the
borders are permeable if you if you set
your story five million years in the
future and there's humans evil then you
have this clerks law that in any
technology sufficiently advanced as
industry
from magic very true like yourself oh
it's magic
so we're already there and the the
distinction between the two is more is
unimportant except in publishing terms
and the the guy who wrote the
encyclopedia of science fiction and the
encyclopedia of fantasy john clewd
writing almost every entry in both
encyclopedias if you can move it he
suggests that we call it all fantastica
to to distinguish it from domestic
realism and in try and instead of trying
to make a distinction that can't be made
between science fiction fantasy you
accept that in fantastica things that
happen that might not happen to you on
the street tomorrow and yet are worth
writing about and talking about and in
fact my teacher here at UC san diego i
was so lucky to have Frederick Jamison
said to me once it's clear to me fantasy
is about pre-capitalist cultures and
science fiction is about capitalist or
post capitalist compounds and it works
like a charm actually so it's a game you
can play forever I see you see a lot of
that that stigma we talk about that
science fiction and fantasy but science
fiction in particular was was some
literary was not real literature it
still has its influences I think and you
see people denying that they write
science fiction when obviously they are
writing science fiction I mean longer
that would classical case here which he
denied oh I'm not a science fiction
writer there are no squids from space
and my stories and you know she had been
formed that switch from space are not
actually necessary hmm although and it
crops up in the strangest places I mean
there bein under my television career at
one point when Twilight Zone was winding
down and Star Trek The Next Generation
was was just gearing up I had an
interview with Star Trek The Next
Generation for been our possible job as
a staff writer and I remember coming
into the office of this producer well
thankfully did not last long in the show
and you can see where when I tell the
story and he said well I don't know I
don't know who you are can you tell me
your credentials well I just coming off
Twilight Zone where I worked for a while
but before that I wrote novels and short
stories I'm primarily a science fiction
writer and he said ah oh really well you
know Star Trek is is not a science
fiction show it's it's a people show
people I was fooled by the photon
torpedoes and the stars would mislead so
would be those I didn't get that job
after you know breaking shameless fun of
this idiot but yeah these these the
crazy denials that you get just mean you
know I don't want to be I don't want to
be tarred with that brush but the brush
is updated and you know the modern
audiences like I think most of people in
this room read all this with uh with
great enthusiasm and don't think of it
as a even as a guilty pleasure or
something some literary and hopefully
that will go away in a few more years
didn't Ursula K Le Guin famously replied
to Atwood that you know she was just
afraid of being stuck in the literary
ghetto and her definition of science
fiction didn't really make sense that's
what I'm remembering I think she did